third floor
hello
you were gonna hey man oh I'm so sorry
and II was just talking a little bit you
want to I don't know if you can
physically sit for a little while but
let me like you to produce the energy
yeah oh you mean to say while he's
talking no stand I'm thrilled to sit
okay all right so you were going to talk
a little bit about something that was
like relative to the decision here in
yoga I was remember the call we have
you're a well just just prompt me prompt
you yeah the the like go long or sad so
it's it's being being a founder or being
an entrepreneur is an intensely personal
decision yeah and so one of things you
and so yet you're also balancing lots of
different interest you balance an
interest of your investors or value
interest of your partner technology
interest or your board of directors and
your employees but ultimately at its
heart at its heart it's the intensely
personal decision and with one of those
decisions the person only the person can
make and so you may make the right one
or the wrong one but it's intensely
personal at its core and it's really
hard for someone on the outside who
maybe investor like us to say come on
man go for it because we have
diversified portfolios of investments
and businesses and in fact if you think
about the concept of a diversified
portfolio I say this the founders all
the time the success of your individual
business or company doesn't really
affect me what affects me is that is the
diversification of 24 companies that I
invested over a four-year period out of
one fund that's all you have but I'm
constructing a diversified portfolio
that I know 60 to 70 percent are
probably not going return the money and
20 or 30% will return my capital and one
or two will deliver those outside
returns so in that in that balance
that's not equal how can you say to
someone you should go for it
so would you back again
in Detroit yield well so here well yes
because potentially because that's a
great set of experience most first-time
entrepreneur having to build a company
having to raise is a copy a copy to sell
it up to balance that could be a good
set a good set of experiences so we're
talking about a company that got a very
very sorely offer as we visit Johnson
but maybe you can so Annie gave a little
bit of his background his career
trajectory that led to a fund would
invest in his company and you have a
really interesting career trajectory
which start I think I should need a
guarantor the rest of my company neither
did you try wide your finesse room I
don't recall but when he asked you a
question all because like it didn't
right no I want to get back to Ed but
there was something interesting that
just happened do you ask him would he
invest in the person who if he took the
term deal which was the early deal right
yeah well the answer the interesting
part there that was interesting is he
would have not known the other outcome
they took that first deal you just want
it now right so I think I think that's
something that I'm always fascinated by
which is people are so crippled by
decisions there's just no way to know
what would have happened you know at the
time we make a lot so much of this is
Monday morning quarterbacking I'm
fascinated so anyway um yeah
I've known this man since I was 14 15
years old because my family had a liquor
store in Springfield New Jersey that I
started working at when I was 14 that I
later turned into something called Wine
Library and launched one of the first
three or four ecommerce wine businesses
in America called winelibrary.com back
in 1996 and your professor here was a
hardcore Y nerd that new wink too much
about not wine for such a young dude and
I was a child but like that was my whole
life and what I cared about and I I
built my dad's business from a 3 to a 65
million dollar business with no capital
infusion in 96 98 to 2003
no no modest and 14 million dollar loan
he but he but he came to America I was
born in Belarus with no language and 100
bucks and lived in a studio apartment in
Queens with a family members so he's
very much my hero to build it up to a
three million dollar level but I did it
on on digital marketing innovation of
the time in 1997 I had an email
newsletter that had 91 percent open
rates because nobody was email marketing
and instead of selling catalogs from
sherry Lehman's or Zaki's I was getting
to customers first but the hottest wines
on this thing email I was trying to send
as many emails as possible 97 because I
thought people would eventually charge
for it like it was just like it seems
such a great deal launching a website
email really I mean you know it's funny
it's like if but but very honestly you
know if we start talking about VR we're
going to make a lot of assumptions right
now that are either going to play out or
not play out in a twenty thirty year
window 1996 internet was a whole
different [ __ ] world and so I kept
innovating about the word wine on you
know they Google AdWords came out for
five cents a click that was a good bet
and no there for a long time and just
did a lot of smart digital marketing
things and then I did it show on YouTube
a couple months after YouTube came out
called Wine Library TV where I sat in
front of a camera and drank four bottles
of wine for 20 minutes
and a lot of people watch that and
that's how I kind of hit the scene in
the tech world and then what happened
was YouTube sold for 1.7 billion dollars
and I was like [ __ ] I was right about
EECOM I was right about Google AdWords I
was right about you know cookie
retargeting banner ads I was right about
YouTube
maybe this skill I have for selling more
you know Bergin Ian and prio rat can be
deployed against something more
financially interesting so when I read
the article about YouTube's sale there
was one article that featured Ron
Conway's angel investor the investment
and I said what the [ __ ] an angel
investor I googled it and did you know
within 20 minutes decided I would be an
angel investor and went to South by
Southwest three months later became
friends with eff Williams and Blaine
cook the original CTO and I think your
firm at the time me and Kevin Rose
bought up Blaine's original stock at
Twitter so I bought a ton of Twitter
real cheap I didn't think of myself as
an angel investor I just thought that
was a smart decision because I thought
Twitter would be big then I went home
for South by made a book well it did for
me because I sold my shares so I did
good but uh came home made a video I was
making wine videos came home made a
video that said Facebook should be
worried about Twitter there was a guy
I've had a platform at the time at
Facebook that I didn't know by the name
of Dave Morin sent me an email like hey
this video has gotten really viral
inside of Facebook would you come out to
Palo Alto and give a talk so came to a
room like this when put in front of the
whole company there's only 400 employees
and talked about consumer behavior and
why I thought the world was changing
that caught Marc's attention we went out
to dinner that night in a week later I
bought a lot of stock from his parents
and then somehow I got David Karp to
reopen the B round of tumblr out of by
the way stick with me here the B round
at a 14 million dollar valuation and I
made an investment into tumblr so the
first three things I invested in were
Twitter Facebook and Tumblr yeah I mean
it was it was when I was smart I was
making bets on things that I thought
would be successful I didn't think of
myself as an investor I got
progressively stupider after that but
because I started trying to be an
investor
I literally went from being I'm a
businessman these are good businesses
this is good the market changed and this
is tumblr be around 2008 be around 14
million now every fake [ __ ]
entrepreneur running around this campus
wants 7 million 4 million for their
[ __ ] idea that they have no prayer
on because entrepreneurship is popular
and instead of going to Bain and
McKenzie they think they can start a
[ __ ] app that people are going to use
um and they're always clapping and
laughing when I speak because it's the
truth we all know it this is the
greatest era of fake entrepreneurship
ever which makes it challenging for
anybody here that wants to go into
venture investing I barely created one
investment for myself last year because
I'm so scared of the early-stage
ecosystem because the supply and demand
curve of actual entrepreneurs that can
see these things through versus
everybody who fancies themselves in that
has broke and so I'm just desperately
I'm so I don't understand macro global
economics well enough to understand who
and why this is being held up for so
long but I'm just desperately waiting
for this whole [ __ ] thing to crash
but here's the interesting thing to me
is at certain point you you just decided
you were getting an angel investor you
didn't know what it was right that's
right I like you just decided that's
what you were going to be I thought
there was a moment in time where the
internet that I grew up and built my
dad's liquor store was starting to hit
true scale and consumer behavior was
about to change for real and so things
like Birchbox and Hoover and other
things I did well with they were all
still back in 2007 to 2010 11 timeframe
where valuations were a little not more
fair but I would tell you that we were
all I was very early-stage we were still
dealing with 4 million dollar idea stage
the differences the entrepreneurs that
were building those companies in 2007 8
9 10 they couldn't breathe doing
anything else
there was no so they didn't they didn't
think they were going to get rich doing
it some of them I think some especially
the early part my south by 2000
experience was wild I went there I said
something about business and everybody
looked at me like I was the worst piece
of [ __ ] they'd ever seen this this Web
2.0 movement the the app growing for the
ashes of the first web bubble these were
people that wanted to change the world
for real
I just wanted to sell more Peter Michael
labor though that's for you that was for
you
so so yeah that's true but they were
also true entrepreneurs every day I meet
every month I meet with 15 people that
10 years ago were going to be
consultants and bankers that now think
the uber of dry-cleaning is their way
out so how do you but how do you
evaluate that how do you evaluate that
person now compared to some what you
call where the true believers so it
really is interesting I've I've really
gravitated later in later stage because
I realized my marketing talent and what
I was good at over the last decade is
actually far better used for things that
have a little maturity to them where I
can use my arbitrage of marketing
capabilities so I become less interested
in the very early stage because the only
thing I now about if I'm going to make
an angel investment pure idea phase I
need to know that that person I'm 100
percent evaluation now is on the person
could care less about the idea and I
need to know if they sold blow pops in
junior high like I'm not kidding like
suck sold like like he like put music on
CDs and sold them in clot like that
salesmanship DNA that grit that I can't
breathe without selling thing is very
needed because the other problem we have
in the ecosystem and we deal with this
is we also have a crazy reaction to
failure I've been up to many dinners
where the dinner is I went out of
business and everybody sits around the
table in a circle jerk of oh it's great
that you learned
my view is like [ __ ] I don't want to
lose my money and like I definitely
don't want to buy you dinner and make
you feel good that you suck but but but
right I mean we lo we have an
unbelievably awesome culture that has a
unique twist to it like I don't know
like it feels very weird that I've
worked very hard my whole [ __ ] life
wrote a $250,000 check the person was
skiing skiing for months before his
company went out of business and then
I'm supposed to go to a dinner and
celebrate the learnings team had in
three years that's broken
that's the softness of our current
culture I genuinely believe that do you
think that's your view because does that
really matter
sure I think it's a hell of a lot easier
to feel the way I feel that because I
walked Kmart when I was 7 and split
toilet paper with my mom versus going a
you know [ __ ] horse man in Columbia
yes and that's up didn't grow oh by the
way I'm talking about me personally I
don't think my path is the only path I
think there's killers that went to
Horace Mann in Columbia but if you're
asking me the question yes I think that
my reaction to that I mean the slang
term for real executors here's what I
know the balance of this ecosystem I
don't know what the class wants to do
whether build their companies are going
invest as it currently sits right now
it's never been tougher at the earliest
stage because you have just so many
pretenders and the truth is it's hard
it's hard to like figure that I can ask
you about you know putting you know
music on CDs but like that's only one
little tiny data point you're really
enough but number of pretenders you have
he's correlated with the rise in the
dollars available to those protests and
the romance and branding of being an
entrepreneur the brand equity around
being an entrepreneur today is stunning
it is stunning for me too in the world
like I can't believe how cool it is in
real life to be an entrepreneur and that
makes a lot of young individuals
gravitate towards that is that but you
but you're suggesting overall that's
worse than if those
young individuals went to work for
Goldman Sachs or McKinsey I am because
I'll tell you what we are not the world
is a better place even with the bad
ideas no I do not let me explain why the
biggest conversation that I'm fascinated
by is the suicide rate at Wharton last
year so we have in parallel a narrative
that anybody can do it and everybody's
entitled to win in entrepreneurship and
there's an underbelly in our world that
I'm concerned about and you know we talk
about this in a different panel this is
a big thing I mean like when you were
there are certain individuals who've
been winning in the first 20 years of
their life in a game that was fixed
before they played it and then they go
into the market and the market punches
them in the mouth and they don't know
how to react and so yes I do think for
the cliche paint picture that I'm
painting right now there are certain
individuals that I just genuinely
believe would have had a better life
being the number seven at Facebook
instead of the number one of [ __ ] book
or or or or making two hundred thirty
thousand a year on Wall Street or
consulting land at 29 years old yes I
think there's a lot of people that will
be better like I love entrepreneurship
the most but nothing works when it's
forced or off balance nothing like do
anything other than gold yeah sort of
right another word unless you're built
for golden yeah what what does that mean
right well I know one thing some peanut
everybody's built to be an entrepreneur
right that's a sea but but it works the
same way to right the other in other
words you used to be right you graduate
school and then you'd go work for a bank
or a law firm you're going to Madison
those were a bunch of right which all
suck it for me but and they may but
people some people still do that right
yes what entrepreneurship is about being
empowered to take control of your
professional life okay right that's some
up do you know many people are not
capable of that that is you know hard
entrepreneurship is the market though
that's called the market
not everyone it won't work for everyone
not everyone who goes to work in
McKinsey or Goldman Sachs was gonna be
successful that's like literally telling
a basketball player that you should
become a hockey player you know that
right
like like self-awareness is very
important and something that should be
debated and I think we're forcing too
many people into
entrepreneurial track that had do not
have the stomach to be an entrepreneur
when you say we're forcing a meaning we
are or Eddie's or who is all of us
combine the ecosystem the press self
promotion within itself the outside
world that that decided it was the cool
thing to talk about for a decade and
then these pendulum swing but what I'm
most worried about and I refer to it
because I believe that this room all
understand it better than me I'm dying
to know why it can still stay up like
there's so much money in the system
there's so much other stuff going on and
government involvement and so many other
variables that are playing out that are
just above my paygrade that I'm
fascinated by when they [ __ ] because
this much fakeness has an inevitable
fate I'm raising fun because I'm going
series B and Series C where I think my
marketing machine that I've spent so my
behavior as you guys know over the last
five six years instead of where I had a
lot of leverage to raise capital and do
my thing I took a major on paper step
back and built a client service digital
social agency that I've grown in the
last five years from zero to a hundred
million in revenue right to give me
leverage for when the [ __ ] hits the fan
and so what I want to do with the fund
in the short term is deployed against
later stage things that meet a marketing
arbitrage to create victory so you've
basically said I'm going to make these
wild investments and I'll do it series B
because that's where the funnel page
works for me they feel a lot less wild
for me coming from angel a so there's a
lot more data of an actual business and
B I can look at it and say okay her
business she's got it all down
her one opening or opportunity or soft
spot is marketing arbitrage the way I do
it which I believe is best in class
that's a good bet for me because I could
bring the smartest money to the table
and so it's not just that you've opened
a barber shop to get paid to do haircuts
in a downturn so that you don't lose all
your venture capital invested dollars
it's
there's a symbiosis between barbershop
even further the reason I in building
vaynermedia right now is long term I
think it plays out for me on private
equity where I buy businesses at scale
and run them through the machine as I
call vaynermedia and make that arbitrage
I took a step back seven years ago and
say you know what now I'm hanging out
with all these fancy people you
characters and waif answered you
Travis Sokka those kind of dudes I'm
like I don't look like these dudes and
chicks
I'm not these people like here's what I
am I'm a marketer and let me quadruple
down at that skill build infrastructure
around that and deploy it against this
world I believe in so that's what I've
been focused on and so wine fits into it
in a couple of different ways I'll get
very real and transparent with you guys
and you know that you have such a unique
perspective on this my dad and I are
very different you know like as
different as you can really get you know
personality-wise viewing the world our
backgrounds as I was building Wine
Library and I was getting more attention
and things of that nature
there was a real forming tension for the
first time in our relationship because
as you know my dad did gave me the
greatest gift I walked in as a 22 year
old and he gave me free rein I ran that
business every decision which is
remarkable in hindsight especially now
that I'm 40 and he was 44 when he
allowed me to do that but as as the
narrative changes the business changed
there was tension between our
relationship on you know him
disappearing from the narrative within
our industry back and at the same time I
made these good bets and AJ my brother
was graduating college just felt like
the right time to like make a decision
where I would hand it more day-to-day
back to him and the management team I
built Brandon those guys so the
real-life answer is for anybody that's
been in a family business the family
business dynamic created a scenario
where because I had all these other
amazing options there was no reason to
create friction with the one of the two
or three most important relationships in
my life that's the real answer and
because I haven't been involved
day-to-day as much I've never enjoyed
wine more because I don't look at a
label anymore and think profit more
you know which has been fun actually
ironically I'm probably enjoying wine
more than ever and you know in a
different way the way that you look at
it because you have such a passion for
it I don't want to buy do jack or things
of that nature but I think I might make
a run at some point in creating three to
eight hundred million dollar yellowtail
like brand just because I think I can do
it and because I want to buy the New
York Jets I don't know that's just
that's a that's a good opportunity for
us to see and unlike the event that any
of you have questions happy to feel them
sir yes sir
inflate what's your name Clifton
asymmetry in this sort of inflated
ecosystem that you can you're the best
you want to be entrepreneurs do you feel
that it has at least provided more good
innovation everyone's have existed
otherwise I don't know is the real
answer my intuition is probably a little
bit yes but I genuinely believe that
great entrepreneurs making great things
like Travis was an entrepreneur before
Garrett was an entrepreneur like I don't
know I don't know not as much as some
people may want to think because I think
those people would have saw it through I
think we grossly underestimate
hardwiring and talent I think we grossly
grossly underestimate hardwiring and
talent I think those things would have
broke through and would have happened
anyway and we're happening anyway but
probably I mean if you have more people
playing the game that wouldn't have
played the game and done something else
of course there's going to be some but I
don't think is much upside and I'm not
sure as much casualty for the players
I'm a net net offsetting game my opinion
what do you think I I think this is
where you and I disagree a little bit
yeah although we agree on some potential
that I think the karma in the world is
increased by more people believing
themselves to be entrepreneurs whether
they have the skills or be successful or
not
I think the Karma in the world is
increased you know so so I think how
something that I also think the internet
itself has created the opportunities
which is nothing else the infrastructure
costs to be in the game are so low
that's as much of a thing I don't think
anybody became more talented or capable
or visionary because the internet came
along I think it's just exposed with the
opportunity and a greater level here's
what's interesting at the same time that
also made it much more difficult for any
individual to succeed because everyone
can do it I totally agree right
I totally agree makes it abundantly much
difficult for us to be investors too
short right I agree but the cost of
starting is so low zero so low you just
say it you're not tripping or mazelTov
so so what so I'm so used to doing QA
I'm like it what are they recording
around you're asking your own guy so
yeah we're on your show what are the
ramifications this fallout for all of
the venture funds because there are some
interesting structural ramifications to
what you're saying right because ah be
there but I do agree that there's
definitely more garbage in and there
definitely you know it used to be that
like it was nerdy it was geeky people
would ignore you they would want to go
talk to people who run hedge funds yeah
that's great and that was actually a
much more comfortable place to be for a
whole bunch of reasons but structurally
we're going to be screwed if we have a
whole wave of venture funds investing in
companies that never should have
attracted investment capital that's
what's going to happen I them a whole
bunch of LPS managing pension funds and
endowments that lose their money by
investing in the acceptance I accept
that accept that software internet based
technology as an asset class is pretty
small so the damage right if if if 50%
of all venture investments got
investments in the venture funds this
year went bust it's it's 15 billion
dollars it's not that big
it's just big for the human individuals
that's real money no no no but it's not
big for like macroeconomic yeah right
there's no there's no yeah that's fresh
first bubble we shifted the risk to the
public yeah that's more meaningful that
we contain the risk to institutional
investor so when we raised our last fund
this year
earlier in the year when we were out
talking our ambassadors we told them
that we believe for the next
years venture returns on average will be
lower than they were the ten years
before and they should expect the return
from our fund and all the funds they
invested to be somewhere between twenty
and fifty percent lower
that's called sandbag yes but it's a
cut-off for believe yeah so you look at
the data the data so are you also
raising money for Union Square Ventures
short fund but our last two investment
you are damn right sister
that's what that's that they work hand
in hand you know I don't get the judge
who should I'm just excited to see how
it all plays out do you know what I mean
I mean who should who should do anything
in the world the people you know what I
love about this is there'll be plenty of
winners during this era
they'll just be a lot more losers you
know and so that's all just a timing
thing this is so classic this is every
market on everything always in forever
it's why I love brands so much this is
when brand takes over reality I know
that was a big statement so so I think a
lot of like so I grew out of my crew
grew out of the angel super angel guys
and gals that were successful in their
first internet business made some money
and we're getting had enough Twitter
followers let's get to the punchline to
attract unbelievable deal flow I made a
lot of them I'm gonna made a lot I'm
going to continue to make a lot of money
from that pocket but a lot of us
shouldn't necessarily be investors we
may be should keeping some investment
behavior but we should all really map
ourselves but yeah I think it's I think
I think all of this comes down to the
supply and demand of the skills and I
think I just think people are very
attracted to this world and I think if
especially when I sit in a class like
this you know my I try to
reverse-engineer every situation I'm in
especially how do I bring value if I
could get one person in this room
to actually pay attention tonight go
home look in the mirror and try to start
deploying aggressive self awareness it
could change the upside of their lives I
genuinely believe that I just hope they
don't work for Goldman Sachs or they
should I mean I really you know or maybe
they should work for their family
business I don't know but I know that
way too many people just go with the
flow I know how strong minded I am and
how easy that is for me to get caught up
and so I just think it's a worthwhile
conversation especially because too many
people make a decision on the now not on
when they're actually playing it out it
doesn't really matter to you if you're
go in this world today matters what the
impact is over a thirty six to sixty
month window in fact you have to really
quantify that looking at data told you
what happened
you need to deploy real intuition and
other kind of signs to what's going to
happen so you can make the decision for
you you guys see this kind of fight
going on craziness going on but outside
this industry do you see any other
industry that was like internet internet
many many years ago I can started to
booming or you know in its early days
but has very great potential when in
real estate does this all the time real
estate gets hot and it gets real cold
when the see players show up and I'm
sure historically every market has gone
through this it's the same old narrative
it's really rinse and repeat you can
deploy the same thesis on this over and
over there's something that's right
early visionaries take advantage of it
get disproportionate returns on it
everybody hears about it the next fast
followers move in do sometimes oh right
and then the worst part happens
everybody shows up so it's interesting
cuz you're York and your concern with
the personal cost I am of that last part
because I nobody here really gives to
talk about macroeconomics they care
about their lives right so that's what
I'm deploying here if this was the
macroeconomic summit
maybe I would talk a little bit about it
but I think I think
I think you can combine him right cause
I think so history tells us that that
bubbles actually may not be a bad thing
either maybe a good thing right away to
figure out the proper allocation you
mean when people agree that's the best
part of the market right like I really
want death right right now like I want
[ __ ] to get carnage cuz that's a good
you know cuz then you send you get rid
of deep layers right you start that
whole cycle over again I mean like
people go to the people go to these
events and like party good I mean like
it's an ecosystem it's a broken
ecosystem people drinking expensive wine
at parties and [ __ ] in Aspen it's
just like I just you know my party stuff
that we're all like it's an ecosystem so
I thought I think the question was like
what's the specific industry that you
would encourage him to go out and attack
right now I don't know what he means is
he knows I don't know an end
timing right like the only thing on the
horizon of our being the internet world
is the VR world but is that 30 years
from now like so many of our friends are
going to lose a ton of money on consumer
VR because they want it to be here in 24
months it's not here in 24 months and so
I mean there's things that are the smart
efficacious of products they are like
that's real like that's the voice space
with Alexan things that there's going to
be places to play there's micro trends
within our world I don't know like and
like things outside of tech you know I
just don't know and consumer direct to
consumer brands is something to happen
over the next 20 years like your
toothpaste is coming to your house the
channel conflicts between retail and CPG
very real there'll be money to be made
so there's stuff but do you have a
timing down do you know which jockey to
bet on
printing and pressing CDs and drive and
having brought a sales process or
whatever I mean being are there certain
triggers you know tangible or intangible
either of you look for in a founder to
to like signal that it's not one of
these of crap companies at your
Ludington I met a founder yesterday and
he's going blind and for the past three
years he's been building voice
application for himself because he can't
see a screen and he was scratching major
screen right and so and it may be a good
business and may not doesn't matter but
but for me it's like are you trying to
solve a problem that you experienced so
you try and solve something that
bothered you you know for you and this
is an extreme example there's a guy they
can see a webpage can't see his phone
but there are lots of other flavors of
that I would say mine lesson theory and
more impracticality there's only two
things that I've liked right now I'm not
investing in first-time entrepreneurs
that have had zero success ever before
let me remind you most of the biggest
wins in our space came from those kind
of people like so I don't think that's
right it's just what I'm comfortable
with right now I want to I want to see a
body of work of doing it before and some
you need a big exit but I want to see
how you rolled because I think the thing
some of the best companies I've invested
in in my last fund the entrepreneur is
dealing with the people issue it's the
people issue they're the right product
guy or gal they have the right vision
they've got a lot of things in place
they're great engineered it they don't
know how to manage people or the people
issue so but I'm a huge fan when I think
of my ecosystem of the people like when
I really poke and prod of the internet
the entrepreneurs that have graced the
cover of business magazines from our
world over the last half decade I know
so many of them got a stunning amount of
them sold [ __ ] and I like it and I
associate with it and that's it like
it's important to me because it shows a
desire to sell stuff and that's part of
building a business and very
black-and-white but there's obviously a
lot of backgrounds that people come from
and win but those are the two things I'm
looking to only
investing in people who actually already
not mean money but something I can look
at and understand not I have an idea
and I think this is cool it's a bit of
the opposite we believe in the drive of
the person that has never done it and
that that wants to succeed so badly but
so [ __ ] cool
so it's just different surgeons no it's
cool I mean it's cool because the truth
is it just reminds everybody in this
room there's no right answer but I do
think there's a right answer for you
and I think that's that's something to
really focus on not because it worked
for that person you admire but because
that's where your strength lies how
candid are you that the person is people
and how do you balance that with and
exactly what you doesn't talk about
about you know trying to help either
people find their way or be frank with
each other or get the kind of [ __ ] I'm
not super candid I hate confrontation
believe it or not and it's a it's a
weakness it's a weakness of mine I'd
rather not deal with the negative vibes
and so I do a really terrible poor
non-noble job in my rejections of
investments possibly maybe maybe maybe
it's more predicated it's for me
personally it's more predicated on just
my general dislike for negativity and
confrontation if I don't have to deal
with it I feel you feel like you just
don't want to be just like yeah is that
what you agreed to come here yeah no
worries I mean I think if you know I
time you know Phil can tell them we're
passing that's just good for me it's
faster and I didn't have to like feel
with the bad feelings like I don't know
that's my truth I'm sure they do it way
more professionally better way to do it
Donna do you we did we deal with I I
think as investor you deal with
uncertainty and so you're telling
someone you're not interested in their
company is your perspective you know and
could be wrong a lot of times have been
wrong well we were wrong about over
we're wrong about air B&B it's just part
of the game yeah
so who knows I was super wrong about
your Bongo what your Bongo I was
obsessed in thesis I was right I was
obsessed with the fact that grinder was
going to become a male-female thing
which it did tender and all that so I
was chasing that space there was a
company called yo Bongo that I invested
in 2008 which was people discovery
highlight one I just kept chasing all of
them and of course it was incubated
inside IAC the one that won but I just
was convinced that that was going to be
a huge winner all my money and my whole
life will be predicated on understanding
people's behaviors slightly ahead of the
market that's what my that's where I win
I just was a hundred percent positive
that people would date in like male and
female dynamics would translate the same
way that male and male dynamics played
on Grindr I just was a hot pot committed
and like I was with social like I am
with with you know with VR long-term and
then you just done it's a timing game
you know roll that that fits their skill
set sort of what's your thought around
that where maybe in some way we're
motivated by the equity either yeah yeah
again I'm I'm so not interested in like
my point of view carrying all that much
weight but that being said yeah I think
that's really right like whatever it is
that is most self-aware if you've got
that roll with that all the way through
not what Mommy and Daddy or Fast Company
or zux told you yeah I mean I think
that's great and I would tell you
another thing we've never lived in the
era where you can get to that person so
easily it's just relentless attack
Twitter and LinkedIn and email and you
can get to that pert little whoo you can
get to if you just try what's the best
way to get to you Twitter I still look
at every mention believe it or not
Twitter's still the best way yeah but I
still look at those mentions it's data
collection for me it's how I make a lot
of my decisions and so of course I'm
going to see the person you know that
that's I'm gonna see it doesn't mean you
know they're more questions
I believe what other people in this room
my interesting career cried out to
school like a junior investment
professional what do you guys think
about this idea do you think there's a
lot of thickness there as well I don't
know what fake mrs. Garrett can talk
about what fakeness is but here's what I
think I think that one of the things
that's interesting about being in a
venture right if you think about there
are you've got two parties there's a
power relationship right and there's
this there's this perception that the
investor has a lot of power so if so
you're it's your ego is satisfied by
being an investor at the same but at the
same time the reality is for the good
businesses a good entrepreneur I dipped
around the other side that's right and
so I don't it took me like I had to I
had to start my company and raise money
until I realized that and I was twenty
years into my career until that insight
which helps me invest now till I realize
it I don't know how how you would learn
problem would venture is that you don't
get paid for ten years you have to be
willing to not get paid for a decade
well I mean okay you I mean you get you
get paid a lot of base salary you look
for the bastards are missing out yeah
yes but it's right like like you know
many people have venture firms just for
the [ __ ] management fees like that's
just real like there's a lot of people
that were able to off their personal
brand in this era build 25 250 million
dollar venture funds and make a real
[ __ ] awesome living just on that 2%
because they are thinking so short term
I said that's real that's a real thing
it's a nice living compared to other
things they're thinking so short term
them because they're also being like why
am I not gonna do a great job yes and I
think others are like because we've all
been there 3 o'clock in morning like hey
listen the booby prizes of great [ __ ]
salary to have a great [ __ ] lifestyle
I mean it's just that's just real that's
not that's not the market there's but
that is but that is the growing that
there is a subset growing market of what
I just described and the other thing is
I'm genuinely believe that this
doesn't have this many people in it
seven years ago right so seven years ago
seven years ago was after only before Oh
eight yeah they were all going to
Goldman McKenzie and Bane and it was
like a third beside the far majority of
this room not everybody but there's an
enormous amount of majority of this room
that follows a certain track that makes
this class have more people in it and
that supply and demand issue is the
problem it is but at the same time I
think I believe one man's point of view
if there's a counter right the kicker is
you had this up on your screen before
right before ten years ago if you're a
venture firm and we're raising money you
had your slide number two talked about
this thing called proprietary deal which
was the way that you got deals right no
one else could see right but here's the
thing they're all just internet
businesses so there's nothing
proprietary you all can subscribe to a
penny and look at the app charts all day
long every day I have no advantage over
any one in this row that's not true
no yes not you sureness no no no no
you're right of course you have an
advantage over him no but you have you
pusher you personal brand equity and for
an equity wait but the entry point yeah
the entry points zero no the entry
points the same correct used to be it
used to be only I saw right right yes
that game is over that game is on yes so
the entry which is why brand matters
more now right but I may have I have
reputation I have a fun that has capital
that will do follow on some charisma but
the but the action about the end you run
how to die but the end point the entry
point is the same you may have an
instrument inside you has a Nana selling
whine about social media that was the
line for you yeah right okay right so
someone else could replicate that a
different way someone else could find
that somewhere today on Twitter on
Facebook right
and so the entry point is same that
means we have to do better we have to we
have to upset we have to hold it you
know our brand new Arctic or it speaks
to why the game we're playing is
actually broken if everybody's looking
at the same data you all end up in the
same place when the opportunity's some
were completely else that's a and very
important yes so that so the answer you
question that's the market to look at
agree to someplace else
market yeah yeah Oh Miley by night
always right you know always though
there's some of you had a hand over
there at the song yeah so you came from
Vader works and now those guys make
knots fun not often meditation machine
Charlie O'Donnell news in Brooklyn Grand
Central a lot of the bigger ones in the
middle is there this hybrid space
developing where you are
you do have an investment vehicle but
you're also committed to the companies
and the people involved you're there
day in day out is the more interesting
integrity with that but if there's more
intricate interesting attire the thing
that happened you know capital used to
be scarce in capital isn't scarce
intention is the last remaining asset
that's scarce and so if that's the last
room in what's the last word attention
attention okay giving someone's
attention and getting someone's
attention so if that's it right so the
advantage that I may have as an investor
is how I manage my attention and how I
manage intention of someone who wants my
money or someone I've invested it not
the capital itself so those things are
kind of interesting like no one cares
more about his companies than Charlie
Adama maybe a good investor he may not
but no one cares no one spends more time
with there's a difference between a
founder letting this goes back to the
case we did today there's a difference
between being a founder led company and
saying I have a really good idea let's
go hire some young person and give them
8% of the company
yes to go they'll stay here and even
though they can make a lot of the
decisions they can't make all this I get
it I am Big Brother watching yes and
it's my money
yeah I'm spending up from LP yes to make
this [ __ ] all happen yes and they get to
move out of my space when I tell them
and they get to hire this person if I
tell them that's okay they're walking
around with a car that says CEO but
they're not I get a the CEO and it
depends on some of those spaces but I've
seen that model a lot and you won't
invest in a company where the CEO isn't
really the CEO and doesn't have enough
equity in business to make it matter
because that person took a job that
person is not a founder we took a job I
understand I'll tell you the reason I
really try hard is because I care more
about my legacy and reputation than
anything else in the world
it's a great place to end thank you
thank you